una nueva noche de disturbios en la
ciudad de filadelfia tras la muerte de
otro afroamericano a manos de la policía
un nuevo nombre que se añade esta larga
lista de nombres que se corean en las
protestas hoy aquí en el oeste de
filadelfia hemos vivido pues tensión e
incidentes con la policía varias
arrestos la noche de ayer fueron 91 de
las personas arrestadas hoy han sido
algo menos presión duda muchísima
presencia policial y es que este es otro
de los episodios que se repite a lo
largo de eeuu ahora aquí en filadelfia
la policía alega que el individuo que
resultó muerto
walter júnior era una persona que sufría
trastorno bipolar que los atacó con un
cuchillo y por eso dispararon es una
llamada la de la the water wallace
juniors que se repitió durante los
últimos meses y por eso es el motivo que
la policia esgrime como para que ellos
tuvieran que actuar en esta ocasión con
esta contundencia que perdería la vida
el ciudadano cuyo nombre se corea en las
calles después de que la indignación
vuelva a hacer acto de presencia y la
gente diga basta al racismo y a la
brutalidad policial